DC Drano on Twitter check this out
breaking news GOP rep Anna Paulina Luna
submits house resolution to expel rep
Adam Schiff from Congress in light of
Durham report findings showing his
involvement with illegal spying on U.S
president it's a resolutions has
resolved that pursuant to Article 1
Section 5 Clause 2 the Constitution of
the United States Representative Adam
Schiff B and he hereby is expelled from
the House of Representatives now I I'm
not convinced they'll actually do it no
unfortunately they should do it and
outside of the the spying I do want to
mention that he published the private
information of an American journalist
once again in an attempt to smear your
family but let's jump into this tell me
there's a lot more to it I mean the
whole thing I remember I've I've done 50
hours of testimony before the various
committees house intelligence Senate
intelligence twice uh house Judiciary
and when he was on house intelligence
and doing that you know I was in front
of that committee and I got out it was
like I got in at like 9 A.M I think I
got out at 7 p.m 7 30 and and I go and I
was like okay guys what happened today
and I'm looking at my Twitter at 7 30 at
night and it's like literally every
bathroom break there was a leak
literally like all you know this is
what's going on in the room and he's
just out there it has to be him right
because like you've never met someone
you guys never met a camera he didn't
love and they're more than you know
gleefully carry his nonsense uh and I
was just like oh my God like my lawyers
weren't allowed to take their phones
into the room but he can go leak to
people from the intelligence committee I
mean these people shouldn't have
classified you know documentation it's
no different than like swallow who was
sleeping with a Chinese spy and It's
Perfectly Natural to leave him on the
intelligence committee I'm like I don't
understand but you know that was going
on I was I was part of three of the big
you know the walls are closing in
Bombshells you you heard many of those
but three of the big ones were me and
one of them was that I had somehow
gotten the Julian Assange uh emails or
information that Clinton emailed before
but the reality is like some random dude
like dm'd him to me I think it was or
emailed them to me it just literally
like spamming like possible Trump email
accounts and like it ended up in my
inbox and I'm looking and I'm like I
don't have I didn't have these things
before they came out and work but they
took it was like 14 right like August
14th or whatever the date was right they
they just deleted the one in the email
so it looked like I had it on August 4th
wow it was released on like August 8th
or August 10th but you delete the one
from 14 it looked like I had it four
days before the rest of the world not
six days after the rest of the world you
know because it's you get a lot of that
spam you know it was just totally like
that was a gotcha moment it's known now
because we have the emails that we
handed over and we have the emails they
used in evidence and it's like no
there's not even a correction you know
there's not even a correction it's like
it's the it's like it's still real and
so it was just that constant lies yes my
Time Magazine cover was truly special so
this is vox.com from 2017. it says
red-handed times latest cover captures
how bad things are for Donald Trump uh
the Russia Scandal hits home by David
Von is it drill everyone said and um I I
think at this point it's now been about
six years uh since This Time Magazine
cover if
red-handed what nothing nothing happened
it was it was all nonsense yeah the
whole thing was a lie but it didn't but
again that didn't matter and that's the
thing I mean even then for us and for me
it's like Well there must be something
to it I mean you know the FBI is saying
these things the CRA like these are
they're maybe leave their honorable
institutions yeah I I believe that I
have friends in law enforcement and now
I know I now make the distinction sort
of between the door kickers and the
bureaucrats right the door kickers like
they come up to me all the time it's
like I can't believe what's going on
it's disgusting and like but like they
also know if they say anything they're
fired or they'll never get promoted just
like they're doing in the military if
you don't if you don't take the facts
times 12 like you're no longer a fighter
pilot we'll just put it
someone else who checks a bunch of boxes
I gotta be careful it sounds a bit
cowardly it is but you know that's
unfortunately you know now the game
again no one's talking about this story
right now it's kind of a big deal I mean
watergate's a big deal they still talk
about Watergate as being a big deal the
people who you know worked on a
Watergate they haven't really done much
since then but they still hold this
legendary status for some reason and you
know they've been commenting Bob
Woodward and others have been commenting
on this story for six years as though
they're the foremost authority on it now
it's all nonsense yeah but like where's
where's the oh we got this wrong where's
the Mia called like it doesn't even
matter you know that's never coming no
it's never ever coming because
journalism is dead and that's why it's
so important what you guys do and what I
try to do it I'm sure what you do as
well I am a journalist on Tuesdays and
Thursdays at 6 p.m
you're welcome um you know we're all
sort of in this together because the
reality is like we're taking on media
and you know some of these things that I
I do actually genuinely believe were
once Noble institutions but like
man
you've gone downhill quick well here's
the evil these people are look I think
that uh when your dad gets reelected we
need an AG who is going to launch
criminal probes I'm not saying every
journalist I'm not saying every Democrat
I'm not saying every uh member of the
intelligence agency or federal law
enforcement are criminals I'm saying it
is clear that there was an attempt a
seditious conspiracy now they're trying
to I'll I'll phrase it this way right
now what do we know
there's something called a standalone
complex are you familiar with the term
I've heard of the term I'm not I think I
think it originates from Ghost in the
Shell to it's a Manga and Anime but the
idea is when a bunch of people all do
something
in in a way that looks like a conspiracy
like if there's a crowd of people and
also and everybody stands up you might
think it was coordinated but it's not
that's what we can say happened right
now but I will say this all of these
people who pushed the lies Hillary
Clinton making these false claims the
FBI then chasing after evidence that was
not correct the manipulation of evidence
to further fisa warrants suggests
probable cause that there was a
seditious conspiracy correct at the bare
minimum I am hoping that we actually see
a real AG get in when your dad gets
reelected and he just says we're gonna
start filing some criminal
investigations likely some criminal
indictments and then these people end up
getting charged I think Adam Schiff is
is is criminally culpable for going on
TV over and over again trying to subvert
this country and and so distrust in our
institutions well and so just reverse it
right and reverse the parties for a
second
if if Republicans did what Adam Schiff
did they'd be in the gulags right now I
mean someone would be in gitmo uh you
know I I use you know I I don't want to
necessarily talk about myself that way
the whole time but like you know if I
was Hunter Biden right like they
wouldn't be removing the team at the IRS
to hand it over to the doj because they
had a whistleblower that whistleblower
would be Beyond reproach
uh you know if I was on video I mean you
know if I did one of the hundreds of
degenerate things like it would be
disqualifying not just for me but for my
father but for him it's okay you know
millions of dollars the shell entities
that were magically formed uh to do
business the second Joe Biden had
authority to do only in the countries
that Joe Biden had any kind of authority
where he could manipulate an outcome
like magically these people are all of a
sudden business people I mean we got in
trouble for building buildings when I
think there's a pretty solid record that
our family's been building buildings for
60 years uh it's you know it's that you
know the the two-tiered levels and
two-tier system of justice right now
that's just so flagrant it's so in your
face uh even those who may hate Trump or
me or whatever like I don't think that
anyone can objectively look at it maybe
they won't say it in in polite company
but when they're sitting there by
themselves at night being like okay well
there's a lot of BS here is uh uh when
your dad gets reelected I don't want to
I don't know if you speak for him and I
and I do think there's something silly
of being like Trump Jr is here let me
ask you what your dad says yeah no I and
I don't because you know a lot of
candidly there's so much every day like
I I couldn't I couldn't keep up with the
insanity to begin with right there's not
enough time in the I'm just hoping that
uh he fires everybody yeah classically
classic Trump you're fired a little
Cobra to all yeah to all the bureaucrats
I hope that a real AG comes in and says
this country needs a fresh start these
these this corruption's got to go yeah
well listen I I do know this and talking
to him I mean coming in as an outsider
was great but you also have the pitfalls
of that which is again you can't fathom
that uh honestly even like a Democrat
politician at the time now we're you
know everything's in hindsight right so
it feels like we're so much like
obviously you know Wuhan lab leak right
like of course it was like now I always
believed that was the core point of
origin but you know did we really think
uh you know our health officials would
literally subvert the health of the
American people they would like you know
we didn't we know that now but at the
time you know what I mean uh you know
one of the things they gave my father a
lot of stuff over uh January 6th I don't
know what I can say on YouTube or not
but I don't think it's controversial but
why didn't he pardon people in these
seven days between that and like we
didn't know they didn't release any
information we were told it was a
violent this we weren't shown any video
two years later we finally get the
videos because Republicans are able to
release that but there's a reason they
control that information you can see
that happen then but in that period of
time you actually didn't know much I
actually think if we look at these the
CNN debate that your dad had with
Caitlin Collins it was he answered
answered rather well she said why did
you wait three hours to say you know no
violence and you he pulls out the tweets
and he's like half an hour after they
breached I said no violence no
violations and then are you gonna pardon
people and he said I'll take a look at
it some people obviously did bad things
and they shouldn't be pardoned he's
completely right yeah No One Believes
you should be able to go punch a cop
randomly but like if you're getting a
tour through the capitol but you know
it's a little different right the police
opened the door for you and let you in
why are you being criminally charged
um you know the video the sound bites
that you hear from that I mean I I think
it demands much further investigation
and honestly the bigger thing is
frankly almost regardless of even if you
did punch a cut I think you're still
entitled to Due Process yeah and that's
the problem that seems to be totally
missing meaning you know due process
doesn't mean we put you in jail for two
years or maybe we'll deal with it
someday and you know even with all of
this stuff going on even with all the
conspiracy theories that have come true
even with everything that we now know
they want to cast a wider net around
January 6. I'm like really like that's
what you're gonna look into not not
people who have real power and influence
in Government manipulating whether it's
you know and I think I it's not election
interference but this was designed to
hurt trump it made midterms harder those
of us who you know I've become a junkie
at this at the time I probably wasn't
right we build buildings that's what we
did like I was into it I was almost
reasonably political but not like I am
now so you know you're sitting there the
average person trying to put food on
their table and they're listening to
five minutes of news a day it's like
well okay there must be something to it
I thought that and I was a Target I was
I was probably the number two target of
them after my father well so let me ask
you what was a
I I suppose it's two-part question what
was the first time you realized they
were lying like they were coming after
you like something was happening and and
how did you feel like it was back 2017
or something I you know it's interesting
you know I don't actually remember I
mean you start seeing it you're like
wait a second like
that's pretty obvious and again
initially even with this stuff I was
like well yeah I made who the hell knows
right they they get you that way a lot
right there's you know some you know one
of the alt-right characters you know
they make it seem like that's half the
country it's nonsense right there's
seven of them out there that you know
but they're like they got a selfie with
Don Jr like I took 1700 selfies that day
like I I don't know who that person is
but it's like we're best friends and the
media will run with that so you know
it's like well I don't know maybe
someone was doing something bad and who
knows maybe they have a picture with me
because I took a a click line because
you're a public figure I took 150
pictures in in a five minute period it
doesn't mean I actually know the person
it doesn't mean I could even tell you
when that happened because I was so
swamped with it but so you're like well
maybe periphery yeah there was something
I know I didn't do anything but then you
start seeing it further and you start
really I was like wait a minute right
I'm actually the right-handed on cover
of Time Magazine and shifts on TV every
day lying about it I'm like wait a
second and and again then for better or
worse I guess you know
I I have a little bit of the Trump Gene
and that kicked in and I was like we I'm
not running from this I'm just going to
engage in my lawyers man they my lawyers
were not in love with me for a while
when all that stuff happened like the
first time when that stuff happened like
I got on TV that night and they're like
you can't get on TV like that anything
you say I was like dude I'm not going to
be called a traitor and and take it I
don't care if if this gets me into
trouble telling the truth and being open
and I did it I put out the you know the
DMs like I guess the DMS from Wikileaks
and Assange that I was like here are
this like I like I'm not what am I
supposed to do I opened a DM that
someone sent me like that I don't know
like am I supposed to and by the way you
know I also didn't come I wouldn't have
even thought about these things
necessarily at the time right like it's
just a different mindset now it's like
okay like what what's the setup what's
the angle I think about these things now
at the time I certainly didn't but I
realized how much more nefarious it is
but I agree with you I mean it's the
most frustrating thing in the world when
you have lawyers being like you can't
defend yourself yeah and they did and I
I just ignored them and for two years
they're like you're gonna get and
finally they they can came up and like
there go you were right I go wait a
minute they're like you know what if you
would have curled up in the corner over
there and you know sucked your thumb
crying for mommy like it it would have
meant nothing you could be worse it
would have actually been worse right
it's it's the capitulation you see that
with like cancel culture right the
second like okay I'm sorry oh the sorry
bloody water there's no honor in it
right there's no if you're trying to do
the right thing that's actually your
admission of guilt to them because it it
doesn't have to be real to begin with
right the accusation can be total BS but
if they say it enough they put it on the
cover of Time Magazine there must be
some truth to it you then try to be okay
let's just settle it down I'm gonna
apologize no no that's the first mistake
because now they got you because you've
admitted that you actually were wrong
and there's no coming back from it
they're not dealing you know honorably
they're not it's not an arm's length
like let's do the right thing exactly
and this is something that conservatives
and Republicans both as individual
citizens and political leaders have
really failed that for such a very long
time left Winger will come at you and
say you're a racist when you're trying
to have a discussion on something like
Health Care welfare policy border
security basic math somewhere where it's
completely relevant and so often
Republicans would respond to that not by
saying all right I'm going to completely
disregard that non-sequitur and continue
the conversation about something of
substance that we were actually
discussing they would go no no no I'm
not raised all my best friends are black
I've never done anything that would ever
offend anyone I let me let me play by
your rules and then your dad comes
around and do American politics and when
these people start asking him these
ridiculous questions and framing things
in a ridiculous way he's like shut up
you're stupid and it's beautiful Rosie
O'Donnell thing was exactly what you're
talking about I think Rosie O'Donnell
but I think that's really important
screaming and cheering I was there and
that was like I'm just like that was
actually when I was like oh he's gonna
win this thing it was interesting when
he called Rosie O'Donnell I knew because
well it wasn't even when he did it was
the reaction of the crowd you know it's
interesting like you know the Brash
billionaire from New York City that
lives in gilded Trump Tower it's like he
still had that connection with regular
people and it was from you know being in
construction sites a lot like he didn't
lock himself in an office all the time
and like listen to the executive he'd
walk a construction site and talk you
know with a guy that's putting up
sheetrock it's like would you ever think
about this this is how to get a little
bit more ceiling height or whatever and
like so we always had those kind of
connections with those guys and he just
got it and that's when I realized
just how much he got it and it was the
reaction from those people you know just
when like when he did his uh his opening
speech you know June 16th 2015 I only
remember this is my daughter's birthday
um
no one said anything about the Mexican
rapist comments because of course that's
going on right now we see that at levels
like you know we've ever never seen
before at the border of you know the
amount of those coyotes yeah all of that
stuff like but everyone thinks that like
that flared up that day it wasn't it was
like two weeks later
when like he actually started gaining
and all of a sudden like oh my God he
could win that's when it became racist
because everyone knew it was real so
everyone thinks that it was like that
was the reaction to the speech no no it
was the reaction to the success of
everything that he was doing about two
weeks later when the outrage cycle
started and all of a sudden it became
racist as opposed to just factually
accurate him with their number one slur
he's a racist then perhaps that would
undercut a success and part of what was
so hilarious about that is during
Trump's campaign they overused the word
racism so much they had to move on to a
new phrase right in 2016 after he got
elected they started calling everything
white supremacist because the word
racist didn't mean anything did you guys
see the stats last week it was like
Washington Post and New York Times like
700 and a thousand percent respectively
since like 20. yes the use of the word
it's just because it's just clickbait
and listen I think social media is part
of that right like I'm I'm not going to
pretend I'm not guilty of some of these
things but like you know everything's to
get that click and you got to make it a
little bit more inflammatory like the
problem with it is like now do I believe
that racism still exists sure I just
don't think it's the cause of a solution
for all of life's problems like it it's
not you know I I travel the country I've
I haven't experienced any of it I
haven't seen it I see tens of thousands
of people a month like all over the
place and and yet there is actual racism
still but when everyone's branded a
racist when you're talking about
economics or math and you're called a
racist because that's like the the easy
button of the political left it does a
huge disservice to those who are
actually afflicted by that and that's
not everyone and if you know I I think
what exactly what we're talking about
right now in more ways than just the
racism issue like every grievance
they've screamed for seven years the top
of their lungs it's just falling on deaf
ears at this point and people are tired
of it correct again which does a
disservice to the small fraction of
people who are actually genuinely
Afflicted either and or you know or
because yeah you now when I get called
like I don't even respond like people
like they said you were racist you know
they tried doing it to my brother last
week he's an anti-semite it's like
that's gonna make you know Thanksgiving
really awkward with my sister who's
Orthodox Jewish like I'm like like what
are you talking about it doesn't matter
yeah like they can just say it you know
well you were near someone who once said
this I'm like did I say it like it's
just you disregard these people at this
point I suppose when someone comes up to
me and says something that sounds like
I'll be like you're not a serious person
exactly exactly yeah I mean if if they
had any genuine concern for the groups
of people for whom they claim to stand
and who they claim to defend and they
would be really careful about the
bombastic claims that they made in the
media to everyone about groups of people
that they didn't like or politicians
they didn't like because all they've
done is discredit themselves over the
past several years so even if they were
fighting for these supposedly
marginalized groups well who would
believe them when they offered up a
solution anyway
you would yeah I mean you made the point
about serious people you're right but
like who at this point
who is a serious person when it comes to
this stuff because like they're all
doing it right it's not like there's a
couple guys that are uh Beyond like you
know the reality is and maybe again I
think it's why they were so gleeful
about Tucker because he he did take on
both sides he called out Republican
establishment you know you saw the I
mean the thing that was so frustrating
for me as someone who's super anti this
insane War uh in in Ukraine uh and just
funding it in perpetuity to let people
die I love my my father's answer on CNN
Town Hall but was like the Republicans
spoke to Politico or the hill or some
other leftist thing uncondition of
anonymity now that Tucker Carlson's no
longer on Fox we can gleefully continue
to perpetuate the war in Ukraine without
fear of reprisal from I'm like wait like
you're a Republican senator you were
elected to do this you know despite what
Mitch McConnell says when he's like
Republicans it's their number one issue
like Mitch I spent a lot more time with
real Republicans like on the ground and
like it's not a top 10 issue for almost
any of them
uh but they're they're gleeful that they
can continue to support an unpopular war
with the people that elected them
because no one's going to actually be
there calling them out because of the
uni party or that you know it's insane I
think one of the things they're very
scared of when uh your dad was on with
uh debating Caitlyn Collins he said he
would end the war in Ukraine in a day
and we had been talking about that about
a week or two before and I said the same
thing I think so he gets in there and he
shuts the whole thing down the issue is
they don't want the war to stop no of
course the worst profit you know how
much money they're making again it's 130
million you know the Pentagon misplaced
220 billion right like if you missed 10
six bucks on your taxes right they want
to go after you if you over a 600 venmo
transaction 601 the IRS is going to
audit you with their 87 000 new agents
you know
but the Pentagon can misplace 220
billion dollars and no one's even like
huh like I wonder where it went it like
it's just like oh yeah you you know how
much money that is like but if they
misplaced it they had a good reason you
just have to trust because while I'm
saying the reality is whatever the 130
is that we've publicly funded you know
we also didn't we we didn't think I did
because I just don't believe anything
they say about the average person also
didn't believe that we had boots on the
ground in Ukraine either because it
wasn't congressionally approved and it
certainly wouldn't be popular with the
American people who you know until
Ukraine sort of became the new religion
of the left replacing uh you know Lord
fauci and kovid as the religion and
demigod uh of the left for the last few
years like the average American is not
for these wars they're trying to drum
that back up and it's because our
generals that's their retirement plan we
get on the board of Lockheed Martin the
way to keep that job is to continue to
sell missiles you don't continue to sell
missiles if you're not actually using
them because you you know and now we're
depleting our stockpiles to do that and
that's everyone's get rich quick scheme
when they retire thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time